hey you guys i am coming to salt lake
city january 14th and 15th get tickets
at estronize.com and i'm also coming to
austin texas february 24th to 26th come
see me at cap city comedy club
estheronics.com today's episode
there you go
hey guys i have a brand new date added i
will be at the la jolla comedy store
next week november 19th through 21st the
philadelphia punch line
uh november 26-27 for thanksgiving the
irvine improv december 2nd one night
only off the hook in florida january
25th through 26th the uh bananas comedy
club in hasbrouck heights new jersey
december 16th through 18th go to annie
letterman dot com shows for all of my
other dates
[Music]
this outfit well i figured for kalila's
birthday
um because i did think this was on
thursday he texted me a reminder last
night i was like oh [ __ ]
um
i thought i would dress up like an
animal she loves animals i dress up like
an animal
i was gonna dress up like you but i just
wore your
i do love a good animal print and i am
so i'm a rescue jealous of this outfit
are you still hungover from your party i
i am yeah this is i was going to call
you yesterday but then he told me that
we were coming in so i wanted to say
this it's kalila's birthday episode
look did you dress like a man she used
to bang or something
what are the [ __ ] i mean they're too big
the shoes my shoes fit
they look i need some size 12's on you
um esther if you if you jump into
something
size 12 shoes
i i might
i might get turned on and yeah to go for
it i'll just put this over
yeah no that it's crazy it's clyde's
birthday today like yeah i guess i just
kind of like forgot
to like do something you could have
easily
maybe
i dress in a ball gown for your birthday
let's not forget
but i have a
question
what
how many edibles are you on and can i
have the exact same amount i'm actually
on
nothing
i'm a little hazy from last night what
happened last night
i big party with popcorn nothing
happened last night but i just took a
lot of edibles right before i went to
bed just because i forgot to take them
during the day and was like i gotta
catch up
i have to keep my tolerance now this is
we have your actually your um your
medicinal marijuana uh nurses here carla
carlos did you do did you give her her
dosage are you the one that told me last
night no no like in general on her own
now oh she's okay carlos how are you
handling the tension in the room with
annie in this sexy outfit i know i
didn't even realize uh my
i know stalker's here lucky that you're
wearing this body suit right now i feel
it why
i mean i never really see you that like
revealing i feel like i haven't it's
just a little different but i'm into it
secretly annie um what's the stitch is
there like a pee hole
or do you have to take it all down where
does it no no i have to there's so much
to sift through underneath too um
my penis
i tuck it back
i have to tell you todd i tell todd i
love him all the time except for two
times when he's too drunk yeah and when
he
manginas when he tucks his penis and
comes i need to get you a guy friend i
want to hire when i this is okay
business manager okay i want to hire a
bro to just like be around when todd
gets out of the shower for him to like
flick his balls at and like do the
things boys like to do okay we're not
gonna do that but you just get meet him
get him for some friends some guy
friends no i already i told you you know
what i told todd when we first started
dating no more friends i said if you
want to meet my friends i have to never
meet yours
we're leveling up
i want to ask you guys about that if you
really like the guy but his friends just
didn't align like you hated his friends
like is that a red flag was that a turn
off for you where you're like ugh like
if they're childhood friends no that's
fine your childhood friends you have no
control over what happens that's so true
oh my god i have stories they're like
history so that's fine but if you have
new friends and they are
at a vibrational level that if they
touch me i'll scream
i gotta go which he has a couple of
those
no we can say hello and move on we're
not associating with these
is that abusive but that's so that's so
right about childhood friends like
there's a radical acceptance of them
because you have this like deep history
yeah with them but it's like i have
one friend in particular who is
so um rude and mannerless and so just
are you friends as a child i don't
remember knowing you
and just like so not what you would
expect if you were to see me like no
that that can't be kaleidos but she's my
friend and i love her to death but she's
so you just described everyone in your
life yeah you did bobby
george is ruleless the way george just
but i can't let her go like i cannot
sever ties with her because i'm like
i've known you since i was is she gonna
know who she is if she listens yeah
because she [ __ ] stayed here this
weekend and she left the [ __ ]
awesomeness
and she didn't even say bye or happy
birthday to me i actually like her so
much
i like that girl i really i really like
i feel at this role
i think i know you're talking about i
love that [ __ ]
but i sense that and i like that she's
she has no rules esther you were good
you were i want to say at kalila's party
you were we had a party we had a karaoke
party in k-town i was a fan of party
esther why party esther is okay i don't
know i had a like a front row view of
esther but esther was um
esther was doing a bit in front of and
dave in front of david called a bit
where she was in a lesbian relationship
with kalila oh i forgot i literally
forgot about something she kept and what
was so this was my favorite moment when
esther was like trying to like freestyle
sing i don't know if another song was on
but she was like what i want to sing
something to kalyali's there's something
that rhymes with kalyan and she's like
hey there kalaila that's so perfect but
i feel like no one heard me except for
you no that's what i that's why i want
to let them know what happened and she
kept going hey guys i just want to like
kalila and i have been planning this for
a while
george will you play that video of
esther oh do you have them yeah
look at those hips
inebriated it's just so good you know
what's even better is that r kelly's
ignition is playing in the background
but it's not the remix it wasn't the
remix
who was saying that's a that's a karaoke
mistake 101. dave probably dave is very
serious about the rules and like the art
of karaoke i feel like he really led the
charge there were you expecting jenna to
not be like crawling
straddling well i was just laughing
because i knew she was on her period
because of her underwear she like lifted
her underwear up at one purge thing up
and she just had like big grandma
underwear yeah and then she was like
straddling you and i was like if she got
off of you and there was a blood stain
oh yeah stomach i would have done you
were rooting for that i just i was like
please leak i have a picture of my head
underneath her dress at that exact
moment you're talking about
and i actually knew she was on her
period and i forgot until i got under
there and i saw was like oh god this
could be a really bad sense as long as
you saw and didn't smell i didn't smell
yeah
yeah she was good she was good on that
front you guys i'm going to be honest
i'm
harboring a secret
oh
and
i can't
keep it in anything she's drinking now
no
brace myself i
uh would like to present my birthday
present to kalyla
oh no it's carlos
oh no and uh
it's wait
no not that you stupid [ __ ] idiot
this is why you don't get paid this is
why you don't make money carlos are you
[ __ ] kidding me what is this guy all
of a sudden she's like i'm hunted by
three days three days is hunter biden
rich
probably yeah if you're the president's
son you're rich okay and you do drugs
yeah you're right i feel like a
president you are the hunter biden i
think oh of this podcast yes wait then
what are we i'm also the chet hanks
i'm all of them
i'm i'm a rich man's son
yes you have rich man sun energy you're
wearing more hats politicians
i always say that there's like certain
hats that you see when people take like
a hat risk you're like your dad's famous
right you can just tell no i feel like
i'm a chelsea clinton
oh that's we've got to stop honestly i
was watching her body and i was i was
not watching i watched your mind
yours oh yeah skating into your well
they're sunglasses but into your dinner
no but i i we have to stop with the your
self-deprecation it's you're in a level
of looks you and your sister i by the
way i got there early to the karaoke
party i'm actually nervous around her
sister she's so pretty i i didn't speak
i was silent we both kind of like looked
at each other awkwardly i feel like i
had a weird vibe with your sister too
because i didn't know how to act my
sister loved you guys she's just a
beautiful amazonian no you both are like
and she put this wig where i'm like
mitch what are you even doing now you're
taking another look it's like yeah and
then i gotta say i don't even want to
like say this into the universe but i
think it's just the truth and we have to
admit it rudy is looking so gorgeous
the three of you i was like how are we
allowed here this is so weird and we
just can't i can't play the shoulder
game with you anymore you're like a
[ __ ] super model you're going i can't
pretend that you there's anything wrong
with you
so i'm not i will stretch your labia out
so it hangs longer or something but
thank god there's i don't know what else
we can do i just sent esther a video of
um me [ __ ] myself
ew
that was her birthday present i gotta
tell you guys on your birthday i wanna
tell you i'm the straightest one here
and i'm
i'm okay with this
i have no you are so straight i have no
homo fomo if you notice me
wait esther who are you but i do kind of
want to see it
i don't get offended hunter biden
chelsea clinton you guys got to help me
out with this i don't know politician
children tiny tim was he a politician's
child
what about jack what about jack the
thing that uh
no the little kid that um
actually i'll give you jack osbourne
that's good i meant jack the i love the
osbourne me too robin williams character
where he was like the old little kid
yeah was that was his dad famous
wait where is my birthday present i have
a present for you okay it's not going to
be as good as this
so no that is some dumb bit that carlos
came up with where i didn't come up with
it oh
my god bend over
carlos take your punishment
yeah wait wait we're amazon
what is the punishment just come back
over and shut the [ __ ] up you'll find
out bending over yes you are bending
over and you're taking your pants down
too you have to
you have to
carlos is even fitter than kaleila why
is
did you um by the way did you uh how
many
uh slivers of seaweed have you eaten
today
you're blocking my camera bend over
oh my god your penis is just out girls
you have a big penis
it's always bodies like his that have
big penis
all right so what am i doing bend over
do what you do at most of your jobs
like towards kalila yeah your legs are
so nice like for a car i'll go shave
them but you know how many girls oh my
god you should transition you would be
cute super model body with a you would
be bald though that would be weird no
we have baldwin we put on the marilyn
monroe wig you got me wait yeah put on
the marilyn monroe it'll look so good on
you because you don't have hair to like
oh
yeah actually
is gonna be this is gonna go the whole
episode i love how the punishment will
happen at the very end george's new hire
has just become like
george is so happy that it's not him
take your hat off
i love your hair oh my god you look like
norman bates
are they saying mcdonald's
you look like you work at norms
i love norms
all right bend over [ __ ]
come on baby girl
and you just rub the tip of his dick
like here i'll do it i'll do it here are
you doing give me a boner
oh my god
this is where we finally really is gay
annie whoever can get him a boner first
is
what the [ __ ] is she doing i got new
nunchucks but i took lexapro four hours
ago wait you can still get a bones you
probably just can't climb back oh my god
oh my god wait is it working carlos
where's my belt
what's cheating
and he does it harder jerking off my
friends the cold metal is not going to
work the hot wood
is doing it like really well
for youtube it's wood on wood literally
this is like
okay hold on i want carlos to sit in
that chair but with it that way
regardless
hold that chair but this direction we're
like we're like doing everything we've
ever dreamed of to carlos all at once i
need you to sit on about like this
what do you do if we actually pay them
money wait carlos carlos that's amazon
style here can i [ __ ] you amazon style
yeah go get on your back whose birthday
is it
oh i think i've had sex like this before
actually
liar yeah what was that
you have to get on your back
you have to get on your back never had
sex liar
steve and bobby did this last week but i
think i can do it better than them okay
get on yeah i should put my pants yeah
your pants are probably they might rip
though so you're gonna go his pants look
why he's so good at a like a startups
position oh
and i think it's like this yeah it's
like samoan it's like hey
crow's your boner
he has a boner he has a boy
he has a voter there's no boner you
shouldn't be yelling there's no boner
you should have a boner right now
oh my god you don't what's the problem
you don't have a boner
what are you gay you don't have a boner
you know i've been having issues with
this and i told you about it really
them you can't get boners on camera
anymore no i told esther i finally got a
boner yesterday at the weed store
oh really that's how good that [ __ ]
keith was you're like oh [ __ ] look at
that one hitter thank you for doing that
happy birthday to me
carlos ah okay what esther what's your
can you beat that gift
yes i think i can you understand that i
when i texted you last night i thought
that we were doing this on thursday and
i wasn't just giving you like that's why
i was like what's wrong with this [ __ ]
i came up with the best idea i guess
i'll just present my gift to kalila um
because i can't hold it in anymore is it
pp
put on ignition remix it's a little bit
it's a it's a little strange like it's
not a traditional gift i'll start with
that
what's a traditional gift from you socks
oh my god i'm like getting really
nervous so okay it's here's the thing is
that it's
not ready ready like i have a photo of
it
that i'm gonna show you this is like
telling someone your gift arrived in six
days and then giving them a little like
i know that's what you think it is but
it's not quite like that okay
so i'm so nervous carlos do you have any
other thoughts of how to set this up i
think just just go forward i'm just
trying to see if the nerves are fake
what's going on here no she's actually
nervous just
just dive in it's not just a dance is it
no it's not a dance it's i'm like
there's something coming from outside
the room
i
can't live without my thera gun i'm just
gonna say it i have been
actually exercising so my legs it's been
a lifesaver
oh that feeling like after a big leg day
when you get that there gun on your
hamstrings it cuts my recovery in half
no matter how sore i am i take my little
protein powder and there are gun myself
and it is a lifesaver it really isn't me
and it's funny todd's so happy because i
prefer it to him massaging me at this
point
it is better oh it's it's so much more
sure better yeah well i go i'm like well
sometimes he wants to do the other gun
on me i'm like todd that's really hard
no but they have the theragun mini and
it's like you can carry it and travel
with it everywhere
you're just talking about it is making
me crave it so much you guys theragon is
the handheld percussive therapy device
that releases your deepest muscle
tension using a scientifically
calibrated combo of depth speed and
power and it's as quiet as an electronic
toothbrush electric toothbrush the gen 4
theragun doesn't just feel good it gets
to the source of the pain by releasing
tension using theragun's signature
percussive therapy which goes 60 percent
deeper than vibration alone whether you
want to treat your muscle tension from
working out an injury or just the
stresses of everyday life there's no
substitute for the theragun gen4 the
oled screen and design make you feel
like you're holding something from the
future just go to their site and check
it out and the theragan app learns from
your behaviors and suggests guided
routines
i'm so proud of this ad
i'm so happy that we're sponsored by
them like
it's just it's really good try theragun
for 30 days starting at only 199
do you know how many massages you can
get out of that yeah that's crazy it's
so worth it it's so so worth it what a
great gift to give someone in a holiday
this was my holiday gift two years ago i
gave this to to dave i gave one to my
family like this is the luxe holiday
gift if you want to spoil someone or do
the mini one isn't it's not even pricey
go to
therabody.com trash tuesday right now
and get your gen 4 theragon today that's
therabody.com
trash tuesday therabody.com trash
tuesday
i love stitch fix you know i love
clothes i love style i like putting
stuff together myself but i also like to
have an outside source help me dude yeah
a personal stylist i know but it's like
i can't afford a personal style no but
stitch fix is like an online personal
style but now we have an affordable one
we don't have to go anywhere it's like
when you're watching netflix and they
see what you're watching and then they
tell you what you should watch next it's
like having that before close stitch fix
freestyle is a shop built just for you
stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and
likes and lifestyle whether you're
looking for a brand you love or to try a
new one at stitchfix freestyle you can
shop a range of over a thousand brands
personalized to your size and fit
with styles for workouts to work wear
for lounging around the house or for a
night out on the town stitch fix
freestyle has clothes for any occasion
plus there's no subscription required
and they offer free shipping returns and
exchanges get started today by filling
out your style quiz on stitchfix.com
tuesday that's stitchfix.com
tuesday to try stitch fix freestyle
stitchfix.com
tuesday
okay
did you guys never see my instagram
yesterday
no i blocked you
i blocked two months ago now
um no oh my god what is it what was it
yes i did see you got a tattoo
i did see your instagram did you get a
tattoo
it
better it esther no this cannot be real
it's not real it's not real
i want to get a tattoo of dave and then
divorce you
i want to say dave show me your arm this
is so funny
that is you're crazy
it's not real
it's real
it is actually real
i think she would have just given you
her location i don't think you needed to
do that i think you could just asked
she's gone to india back i don't know if
you needed that esther show me all right
show me this i hope they spelled it
wrong okay before you get too
uncomfortable
there is a caveat semi-permanent
it is semi-permanent but it does last 15
months oh my god will it outlast the
podcast guys
will we still be your friend uh what is
the tattoo i got a tattoo on my arm that
says kalila
and
uh yeah it's
it's this place called ephemeral tattoo
i literally just read about it i read
this article about it and it's
semi-permanent so they add them like
real they do it like a real tattoo but
the ink disappears after 15 months
so that's 15 months
of devotion oh yes until my next
birthday
are you uncomfortable
i here's what i'll say
here's what i'll say i've been with
bobby for eight years and he has never
shown a like a big gesture of love like
this so
um
you can do anything for the next 15
months and i'll probably
love you regardless like you could light
my house on fire let's do it that's what
tattoo is that's a spider house that's
what the tattoo gets you just a free
pass at sexual sexual as well you kill
me like um
this is a good outfit to get shot to
death no wait should we all get each
other's names
i mean if it's 15 months i'll do it yeah
now when i tell you that dave was upset
that i did this
[Music]
when i tell you that there was a fight
but you did it i like that you did it
before talking to him is good
no i he knew and he was like wow are you
serious he was like if we get married
this will be in all of our photos oh
yeah you can't get married for 15.
well we just postponed the wedding
i literally thought i i don't know okay
what is i was like this is a great idea
but now i call bobby and and show him
this is i'm actually nervous to tell
bobby why like is he going to be like
you're a freak like you're obsessed with
are you worried about if bobby lee
thinks you're a freak
if bobby lee thinks you're normal you're
in trouble
oh my god esther i love it so much my
heart is really you guys okay i knew my
trash [ __ ] slugs i feel like we were
bored we should get each other's names
now for christmas i'll do it yeah okay
here we go thank you
i will wash them and prepare them oh my
god annie went to the booth barn and got
me what silver coat oh boy booze price
tags
at a zero they were on the opposite of
sale
[Music]
i hope they fit they didn't have that
many options but i did like the
sparklies it's so annoying that that's
clearly a better gift than mine no no
yours is a better gift and
it definitely should have gone second
but you know what else i'm getting you
but it's not i i thought of it in the
shower today
i'm getting you um i'm buying you a
merkin
what's a merkin it's a it's a wig it's a
toupee for your vagina because you have
no hair that's really funny
we're gonna get you a moment what a sad
day if the bush is fully back and i just
cannot be on that look at her vagina
dude those things are but those boots
look hot keep showing me the boots
her vagina is through the boots she's
like this and you can just see the vag
i mean there's underwear but it's is it
uh american flag underwear it's a like a
good refugee oh my god god
like kalila when you were in your outfit
the outfit she wore to karaoke was like
crazy her body's like another level like
obviously she was born with like
a gifted body but the peloton
yeah the body is it's unbelievable
thank you it's a rig
it's meant for work my trainer uh wants
to hold
i've always wanted to drop you into a
cold bucket of water that's so weird i
have a feeling i always wanted to pour
water over your face while you can't
breathe i'm really cold and tolerant so
i might be the first one out but i oh
really i think i would be the first one
but don't you think if you put well we
should definitely do like obstacle
course style stuff we'll have to set
stuff up okay is there a sauna right
next to it yeah okay good oh i [ __ ]
love a sauna well we'll try to beat
rogan's what how long was rogan in that
ice bath he looked like he was either
coming or struggling i couldn't couldn't
tell if
yeah
we went to uh like a halloween party
that whitney threw to celebrate like her
i saw that her drink june shine yeah
and then afterwards i got a text from
annie that said you missed the flames
and i still don't really fully know what
she meant well guys
let's just say
things got heated
at whitney cummings june shine party
what happened okay so esther showed up
for two minutes it was actually so
[ __ ] annoying there was a photo booth
in the back i'm i turn around she's gone
it was so crowded
didn't you feel like it was a really
crowded part but here's how i feel as a
little
like mouse-sized person you shouldn't
care about the side you can weave in
between legs there's so much space for
you
for me i've got to bump into shoulders
collect kaleilas
chests
you can just
you have that like center of gravity
that's the center of gravity
but i could see you getting knocked
around
yeah
honestly i just felt like because there
are people coming and like who are not
our friends right no it was weird and
some were our friends but they were in
makeup and i didn't couldn't tell also
also there was a vaccine requirement to
get in and i saw people there who are
like actively anti-vaxxed oh i know
exactly who you're talking of course you
do
who i didn't recognize by the way no i
had no clue that person was there
i was a [ __ ] shaman a [ __ ] shaman i
this was i did five i did four or five
costumes
this halloween
um and this one was my favorite it's
like paris hilton's 21st birthday party
how she celebrated it five times
each decade i okay so i well i just
don't want to wear the same thing i feel
like i'm creative i can use my brain i
can come up with a new one
i did kind of blow it on bangs i'm not
gonna lie being girl with bangs was but
i thought that was funny and then esther
was like no they look great i'm like
okay
[ __ ]
thank you i think you should get bangs
oh you're a [ __ ]
mark mark this moment
that's a saboteur you're gonna see i'm
i'm gonna get bangs because of that like
they looked so good you have a different
situation going on that's not true we
both have round wide faces and mine is
worse
what is the criteria for um bangs
looking good on a face i actually don't
know
it has to all i'll say is every time
i've asked for bangs i've been told
absolutely not like i've never met
everybody that was giving me the
clip-ons was like no and i was like
really it's gonna be funny just give
them to me i had to talk her into it and
then they fit on randy and they look so
cute on randy like the perfect little
one okay so i was a [ __ ] shaman so i
wore my the outfit that was supposed to
come in for my friar tuck [ __ ] fire
truck outfit was a [ __ ] little dress
so i put the [ __ ] little dress on i
got a cultural appropriate
um
like
native american chest piece from the
costume store
um i put lots of hairspray and i like
teased my hair really big
and i drew an eye on my forehead and i
put like a fake eyelash on it
and i got a bucket
and i couldn't find fake vomit so i had
like a a plastic turd which honestly you
kind of like
it looked like you but i was like oh my
god twins twin costumes
um
no but so i i had a turd in there i had
incense
a thing of sage and a joint
okay and i was walking around as an iowa
a [ __ ] ayahuasca shaman so i had the
bucket with me and i had the incense lit
and i was walking around with the
incense i think it was a pretty cool
costume right interactive
then i'm sitting at the table with
benton and a bunch of other like hot gay
guys there was one guy just painted in
gold he was so hot and then his
boyfriend was a gold digger it was cute
oh that's cool but they were like so hot
and there's the opportunity for me let's
smoke this joint let's smoke this joint
i know that one is collapsible
bobby should just be all in gold and i
could just be myself that's our costume
[ __ ] but anyway so someone's like let's
move the joint and benton i've never
smoked weed within my life i didn't even
know he smoked weed was like let's smile
because smiles i'm like all right i'm
like we're inside this bar and they're
like well you have so many other things
smoking they won't be able to tell so i
get the bundle of sage and the joint and
i have this brilliant plan i light the
incense in the bucket which is sitting
on the table here and i light the sage
and the joint at the same time we're
passing the joint in the stage and
people are smoking it like this holding
the sage and smoking the joint
okay it gets passed around one time
before the guy the security guard comes
over and goes you can't like what are
you doing you guys can't smoke in here
and right as he comes over in my hair
engulfs in frames my hair extension
catches on fire
i'm patting it out
it's it's absolutely insane like i'm the
biggest flamer at the table now
i couldn't believe it like it was like i
was in shock i was like this couldn't be
funnier it's not my real hair it's fine
he didn't stop dropping roll i i didn't
have to but i did i did stop drop and
touch my rolls
and then um
so then my hair burns i'm like oh my god
there's like little peas i'm like oh my
god and then i go to whitney i'm like my
hair just got involved because did you
catch it on camera she was like she
couldn't have said it
[Laughter]
i was like i don't know i hope and her
guy said in post i'll add flames if you
didn't get it but it was so funny and
then todd wanted to stay but i was like
listen i can ruin a party with my
personality i can ruin it with my
loudness with whatever with my making
out breath
that's my thing
does project
um
i can't ruin a party with the smell of
hair it turned into like a murder
mystery party where everyone's like what
happened what's going on everyone was
sniffing around i was like it's me i
can't be the thing everyone's saying
well you know the only thing i want to
know as your business manager is did it
ruin your hair extensions i immediately
went and bought new ones the next day
well people are like oh my god i was
like it's okay i'll just buy more um but
i brought the hair extension it might
still smell can i clip it on my head
right now yeah it still smells a little
bit
so there's like they're singed on the
ends oh no
beautiful blonde locks i got a better
mind
yeah
anyway that color looks dark now
after karaoke after um a small group of
us um
decided we were going to go to the strip
club this smells like did you go to the
strip club do you want and
can you believe that dave had had enough
it was just it was i you know what i i
in my head and the moment i was like i'm
too tired i won't enjoy it but you know
what now i know we need to plan a
different before we go to a strip club
yeah carlos we got there and it was too
late and they didn't let us in but
uh oh really we did it was a valiant it
was just youtube no it was like
the [ __ ]
it was all it was almost jenna was there
what are you trying to prove yeah i know
i can't imagine jenna being like i'll
sit this one out i liked how much jenna
was saying i thought it was funny
yeah i was i was having a jenna jenna
appreciation night yeah jenna's a
absolute ham
i was like i love seeing you with um
hanging out with kevin bacon not to be
weird she was like it's not weird but it
is like he's just my friend's dad and i
was like i know that's why i thought it
was weird
on a farm
they're just hanging out with goats and
stuff and a guitar i like are they on
the footloose like grounds
i'm like is he just always on the
footloose set
it was really fun though i had a great
time and i hate karaoke but i was i'm
warming up to it i have to go more i had
a really good time um with your
boyfriends oh they're great yeah
interesting you know they they took
shots with me oh yeah that was cute oh
yeah
i think todd and dave are so fun yeah
they're gonna have fun together in a
while yeah
i'm gonna have a lot of fun with them
i know
bobby's not coming right
well he doesn't know yet okay i'm like
yeah todd might just be with george
she's gonna have to get to work nothing
else to do bobby hasn't gone to a single
one of my birthday parties over eight
years yeah how do you feel about your
birthday party like was that like a
successful one like yeah i didn't know
um exactly like what my sister was
planning who was gonna be there i just
know she was like yeah let's do karaoke
you know and so that was really sweet of
her um
i
i was i just i felt like i i didn't have
a clever costume usually i always have
something clear like you look happier
it's like honestly i've literally never
seen anything like it you looked like a
like a
a goddess native american barbie doll
what were you
i was a cowgirl she was so in this pink
like seersucker it was like
i i truly have never i mean you're a
goddess i don't know what else to say
you're no longer allowed to be in the
self-deprecating well let me tell you um
the weekend took a toll on everything
there's a reason why i'm wearing
sunglasses like my body is shot to [ __ ]
because you don't usually drink i don't
drink and i was taking it down
well you saw i had two bottles of don
julio like oh did you yeah i was just
shot after sean
i actually didn't see i don't like i
have no awareness of alcohol until
people are wasted oh yeah
i don't i have awareness of it either
but i wasn't like
i took a shot at on julio oh he's a bad
relapsing boy
come here carlos yeah carlos you
shouldn't be drinking
i didn't know he was talking you're
sober carlos i offered you that drink
well i wasn't he's bad for over 10 years
no he didn't relapse there oh my god not
on my birthday right
what did dave say to you that's more
drastic than the tattoo
dave um was like hey is it okay if you
take this shot everything's gonna be all
right
and i was like yeah it's fine and
yeah it was totally fine oh my god i
have a sudden feeling of dread why no
i'm not not into alcohol
no he's always drinking he's a bad he's
a bad boy you need to stop carlos i
never drink but why he wasn't doing it
bad he was the kind of tone you want to
take with one of the stars of the show
here
i know you're getting my drinking we're
gonna start charging you to work on the
show we know we can't take any money
away because you're not being paid
annie's had this joke for years oh it's
a funny joke
at any job no you get paid paid as being
a society about the dog rescue
your rich dad sends you money i got paid
at the dog rescue
but how much is the dog rescue paying by
the way
they paid you in kibble decent amounts
they go love and experience and money
they didn't make you bring your own dog
treats they let you use their dog treats
yes i could steal them if i wanted to
you never did you never stole them for
me
okay well that would have been too big
of a haul
esther are we really at the airport we
have to have you crawling around as a
dog yeah we have to try it muzzle her
please
[Laughter]
muzzle you i'm the muzzled i'm the only
owner that gets muzzled to you if you
walk her like a dog but you're in the
muzzle
guys we should do an episode do you know
that in high school
now i'm like is kalila high today
i know i was kind of hoping you would be
on edibles
the dirty little knot so secret about
the bedding aisle is that while cotton
might be the most popular fabric for
sheets duvets and pillowcases it's also
the most damaging to our planet and even
even organic cotton takes its toll and
that is why we are so thrilled to
introduce you to attitude made from
naturally organic bamboo which is good
for you because you're used to living in
the forest yes and i want to again
attitudes sheets are made without toxic
chemicals and use 500 times less water
than cotton plus they're silky soft so
they're comfortable for you and the
environment i
love my attitude sheets you don't
understand they're so
soft and luxurious they make me feel
fancy they really are they're nice i'm
as someone that's used to just having
crumbs and bare mattress
this is quite a leap and it's perfect
for me for someone who runs really hot
when i sleep because attitude sheets
wick away moisture and regulate your
temperature to keep you cool and
comfortable throughout the night none of
you have to sleep in the wet spot with
attitude
try any attitude betting for 30 nights
if you're not completely satisfied
return it for a full refund right now
you can get 20 percent off your order
plus free shipping when you visit
etitude.com
tuesday and enter promo code tuesday
remember that's attitude as an eco
attitude order today for free shipping
and 20 off your order at editto.com
tuesday promo code tuesday and honestly
these are a great gift for people if you
want to up their
their sleep time which is probably the
nicest gift you can give someone
you guys i'm not kidding you neutral
full works dude i know
if you're patient this isn't like a uh
overnight fix if you're patient and you
take neutrophil
as suggested you will your hair will
grow nice and thick
i can attest to this no and you guys 30
million women are impacted by weakened
or thinning hair if you're among them
you're not alone and there's a solution
that can trust that you can trust to
deliver results thousands of women have
taken back control of their hair with
neutrophil with many users raving that
the supplement not only transformed
their hair but restored their confidence
too so neutrophil offers two targeted
formulas for women that are clinically
shown to improve hair growth and
thickness with less shedding through all
stages of life and the healthier hair
growth it takes time okay you'll begin
to experience thicker stronger faster
growing hair in three to six months in a
clinical study eighty-six percent of
women reported improved hair growth
after six months
more than fifteen hundred top doctors
recommend neutrophil as an effective and
high quality solution for healthy hair
and honestly
when i stopped birth control and when i
turned 30 my hair just started to just
come off my head so this has been a
lifesaver can we have it
the hair a bundle of it save the dna to
recreate give it to us we're going to
clone you you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month's
subscription this is the best offer
anywhere and it's only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get 15 off at
nutrafull.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-dot-com
trash
oh wait i have something for you guys
my uh my i don't really know what to
call her my girl that helps me with
things that's so cute and great
um she made these for us your personal
hype man
thank you oh my god gifts upon gifts um
came in here yeah she just made them she
came and she was like i thought maybe
you guys could like give these out to
people oh that's so cute she's got good
ideas portia i have um shout out portia
thank you for these thank you um esther
came in here and the first thing she
said she was like coco what's no not
november
oh come on what is it though what is it
why don't you guess what it is do you
think it's about food allergies um
almonds no i'm no not november sounds
like a guy who doesn't come for a month
but why would that be a thing
that's like bad for your prostate but
it's good for your creativity
it builds up that root chip is that true
like i'm genuinely curiou why is this a
thing i think there are people who are
obsessively masturbate to porn who just
do it every day without thought as sort
of this thing to do you know how you are
released porn she sent you of yourself
i do want to see it but are you here's
the thing are you being like a real are
you coming for real are you doing like a
a show for her i'm doing a show yeah i'm
just basically fingering my own [ __ ]
my old
i didn't actually see she deleted it
graphic anything it was too much
no it just
i don't know why she's
i
it's just i don't want to get in trouble
when my fiance watches the show anymore
you know the fact that you still have a
fiance is like the miracle of the world
dave is
dave has never been down
with anything you've ever said no
i've known you a long time it's never
been
going these are great ideas i love the
way you're making me look
and you've taken it to a new level where
i'm so impressed with dave
i think he might actually like you
no dave is a good guy he's a good boy
he's doing a good job i understand he's
a professional man people know you're a
power couple of sorts yeah should we not
should we do no nut november
sure
what would that mean i've got a blizzard
i mean this is so mean but what does
that do for you well i don't come what
do you mean college
no not college yeah i feel like that's
the whole guys were banging
when i was with the sock i'm like i
could have been a [ __ ] sock
i did the knob nom challenge once which
is one month without booze and without
masturbation
okay very uncomfortable where's the bell
go well like
by the end of it you'd i'm calling
you're jerking off in a whiskey bottle
because it wasn't no sex there was just
no uh no masturbation oh
so i called two exes that i should not
have called
and then like by day 30 your wife was
just going to sleep your baby was crying
your wife was years ago wait i have a
question about that george i just
imagine being george's ex and hearing
his voice on the other side
wanting to rekindle things
what do you think that sounds like um
hello hello are you what could the
what did you say
what's the sound that pushing your
glasses up
wait george do you sext no
okay no you don't seem like a sex doctor
i never i'm not really a sex anymore
because i've really it's it never i was
always like kind of faking what does
your wife think that like you're at this
show all the time and like kalil's labia
is out like annie's [ __ ] like what is
gaping her my hemorrhoids just hanging
out
hang out like my hemorrhoids like
annie's always naked like what's it's
work it's work okay esther what are you
just watching
you're sick little boy
esther someone else told me you killed
two at the comedy store it wasn't just
me really
waitresses that's crazy yes [ __ ] do not
hear the laughs
i don't know what i feel i don't know
what i feel with my stand up but i i
don't it's good you should go see her
it's good also i gotta do this okay i
don't even like her i kind of find her
to be one of the more annoying people
sleepover by esther is so good it's not
so good
i spend money okay i buy a lot of like i
i have like a chunk of money that i
spend on sweatpants like this is my
thing here's what i'll say about
especially the pants so good top and
bottom are great is that it makes my
waist look smaller because the band is
exactly how i like it it's the length of
your shoulders
it's as wide as your shoulders
but it's so comfortable it's just it
it's so um
it honestly is very very becoming it's
flattering very flattering i'm so glad
you guys like it that means so much i've
been wearing it every day i wore it
every day in the desert it brings me so
much it's it truly sparks joy because
it's like for me it's just like a fun
hobby where i'm like i can make things
as nice as i you know
she has someone else make them which is
so funny oh yeah no i don't do it no but
you you going guys this moves me like
this is stoner story guys this moves me
i'm so excited i'm
thrilled why does it just sound like
trump but tired did i sound like trump
no that's what i'm saying
no yeah you're you're just um
you'll be relaxed and sleep over by
esther
[Laughter]
i get no kickbacks for this honestly it
actually hurts my heart to help her this
way
they're so good they're so comfortable
it's the only annoying part is that
they're very like noticeable so that you
can't i can't wear them every day that's
why i did i'm doing some solid colors
coming up so like if you're embarrassed
of wearing the pink ones every day like
you can blend in better uh you really
did burn
the [ __ ] they went up you have to
understand like they don't look burned
they they were engulfed like it was
going up like i almost didn't have lip
that was almost the last night i had
lips
dude that's really scary
what are is it banana break time yeah
[Music]
i just swallowed
a little too deeply uh oh something
wiggling in there i'm just old old
festering calm how old are you how did
you do 37.
i was thinking about it too i kept
looking myself in the mirror i was like
i'm like 37 i don't feel it i feel like
a kid yeah that's what ever people say
that though at 90 it's never gonna stop
i think we just all pretend at adults
nothing is real esther will yeah no
everyone's just a tall baby like you're
just a tall kid
yeah you don't change it's just you get
a little like more responsible you have
different nights it is freaky that
everyone consistently says that the time
goes by
like so fast they haven't hung out with
you
they should watch esther club actually
watch old effortless club your life will
slow down
[Laughter]
i was watching a clip of us when um
we were doing either esther club or my
podcast were zooming
and a dog attacked you it's like one of
the funniest things it's the best one
you're look i feel like i'm taking this
over i'm like why is are you falling
asleep is it boring
and then some dog
you're a parent's house your parents dog
or your old dog attacked you it's one of
the funniest things
he's very pepper is very aggressive she
started crying
and should we call bobby and show him
your tattoo
yes yeah i'm scared yeah what are you
scared about well maybe he's on set but
let's try i just feel like he's gonna be
like that's weird
like that's he's like well he's worried
about people saying that's weird when
they look at you
oh santino's calling me oh pick it up
yeah you know i called and i was just
trying to i was originally trying to
leave you a voice message singing happy
birthday to you and uh
um an old white guy voice but i picked
you up
well here let me hang up you can try it
yeah old guys we're
okay bye
it's bobby it's bobby hi sweetie what's
up babe
esther wants to show you something
esther sent him the picture right now
okay what's the picture of what esther's
birthday present to me you will not
believe it i like your nails clipping on
me i'm really scared you want to see it
yeah text it to me
okay it sounds exciting stay on the
phone she's texting it to you right now
is she [ __ ]
crazy
is she dumb
[Laughter]
is she dumb and crazy what is wrong with
that girl
i can't believe you called our girl
she was dropped
you were by many agents actually what
does drops mean but as a baby in your
head yeah
no they never held it whatever you want
to say
anyway why did she is that real it's
real
well you're gonna have to [ __ ] get
her an astropop tattoo now
i have to do it yeah yeah on your neck
right over adam's apple
all right babe i love you
that's so funny
okay here's andrew's um white man happy
[Music]
birthday to you
that's pretty good it's pavarotti i
loved that that was
gorgeous
you can still sense the anger that deep
down anger yes as a gender
all right guys let's do the filipino
newspaper dance
what's that
my homeland's tradition esther just get
on board listen you're in the family now
hair
ink on skin okay annie get a piece of
newspaper just this size
for you and your partner esther
carlos will you be my partner yeah okay
she needs a partner that she knows is
not sexually attracted to her wait i
already have one of those wait
oh my god the sexually violent predator
next door is the one i got and that
actually chose you so yes i must be
getting prettier all right this is how
it works we're going to put these on the
ground oh this is for you too it says
just what does manchin
let me explain the rules we're going to
put this on the ground and we're going
to be doing this in pairs so when the
when the music goes on you're dancing
with your partner and when the music
stops you hop back on the newspaper oh
and each time you fold the newspaper in
half and and you have to so the person
with the smaller feet wins
correct and so if any of your body any
of your foot is outside of the newspaper
you lose but each time you fold the
paper it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller carlos i don't know if you're
carrying me if i'm carrying you carrying
what do you mean
you'll stay out can i opt out of this i
want to watch i want esther to carry you
i'll masturbate
esther broke her toe
on something that is made of foam okay
i don't want it before hawaii be the one
that puts her in the [ __ ] because
then you'll be pushing she's gonna get
one of those for no reason
okay here we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah there's our strobe light
okay oh
okay we're good now fold it in half
these moves aren't great yet guys
how do you
look rust
carlos you're [ __ ] up i'm ready no
carl's last night guys i don't have to
try and i win
we're not supposed to go way further
than that the newspaper is supposed to
be
oh by the way i thought i caught this
young foot fetish guy looking at my feet
i was like i gotta start wearing socks
out this is ridiculous i was at
lunch with todd this and i was like wow
i've never seen a foot fetish guy so
young and he was with his young hot wife
i was like why did he want my feet and
then i looked he was looking at todd's
yeezys
i was getting like almost like we need
to move seats i was like this is getting
gross
so i had exactly one week of
the best dms ever just hands man hands
man hands man hands oh my god and then
oh then someone then the dick pics came
back and now we don't want them it's not
good we don't want them so i'm here to
remind you guys please no more with the
dick pics the hands is where it's at
there's no dick that is
looks as good in a picture it's not so
it's like no dick worth photographing
yeah there's no we want to forget them
honestly it's like we put them inside
ourselves real quick hide them in there
i do feel though
i did get one dick pic that was so bad
that it was good it was
it was a long angular penis but it
wasn't about the [ __ ] it was about the
it was shaved to shaved areas
uh he was sitting indian style
with his feet like like his feet like
heels pressed together and the penis was
like laying atop it and it was
the let me try to get
heterosexual move i've ever seen
it was the gayest move a straight man
has made towards a woman
that i've ever seen
yes
like it was just laying on top of it and
it was just i mean it's it was so funny
actually when i first started dating
todd
i had we'd been high in the back of the
comedy store and we were talking about
his dad for some reason i didn't know
anything about todd really at that point
he just was like we were just laughing a
lot i was like oh we laugh a lot and you
guys do laugh a lot together
we have fun all day long it's like
always fun we wake up just well todd
says that he wakes up in a full
conversation
yeah because i'm just already talking
yeah
but um so i made some joke he said
something about like his friend's mom
dildoing herself he goes it was some
like something funny that made me laugh
and i go well i have a question for you
have you ever like [ __ ] your dad and
he's like what and i just kept saying it
i was just so high and thought it was
funny so then i found a picture i went
online
on facebook i found a picture of his dad
and i've shown him that penis i'd shown
him the penis that was lying on top of
the feet
and i photoshopped that penis onto a
picture of todd banging and i put his
dad's face on him
and i sent it to him like a hundred
times it's true love and that's when we
knew
wait i not to until the month i really
have to pee go pee can i go okay yeah
i'm sorry is there anything fun
happening when you come back is that a
real pee i genuinely just have to pee
wait can we get a bucket and have her
pee in here what what is this show why
not
we've already peed in diapers right
diaper she did it again she always does
i don't know if i should tell you what i
was planning because we could just do it
another time i'm gonna do it i'll do it
another time i'm gonna give you a
birthday surprise randomly throughout
the year
that you're gonna love look guys i feel
really really
showered with love and presence i didn't
expect this i was going to write you a
poem too i can freestyle one yeah when
esther gets back i wouldn't need you to
freestyle and okay a super emo poem you
want to give her your other presents uh
that you got are that in that bag
i got you this by the way i'm wearing
black on my birthday episode because i
feel as though i'm in mourning because
bobby has gotten my birthday wrong every
day this week wait what do you mean he
greeted me on a thursday and i was like
my birthday's not until five days and he
called me the next day and said sweetie
happy birthday and i was like it's still
not today and then he called me two days
ago he's like i love you so much happy
birthday sweetie
and i was like we've been together eight
years one year you're going to get it
right this is not about your birthday
this is about him not being able to tell
time
this is like you gave him like a bigger
measurements of time and he didn't
get inject
are we do have we planned hawaii
activities i want to know what you guys
want to do there that's my my concern is
like do we throw esther to the sharks do
we not
no esther always has the option to opt
out
esther here
because i think my sister's coming with
me if my sister and i surround you and
we go on a shark dive and we're we we
have you in like
our arms are linked and you're just in a
floaty around us will you put your head
down and look at a shark underneath
maybe okay i feel like it's the more
safe
i i want to do tropical look i want to
eat pineapples we knew it was going to
be an eat we knew we didn't know what
exactly the food was but we knew it was
going to be an eating situation i want
like tropical vibes do you want to we
got to give her a poi
yeah i don't think she's gonna like poi
let's be real and yeah i love poi maybe
she will she is a poi of a person is it
like
tropical climate where we're going she's
a substance tropical yes i wanna
though a little bit
it's their winter but it's still very
tropical okay okay i want to see this
a tesla t-shirt so you can advertise
annie's tesla
it also points to your puss
and
not to be a tesla hat does this mean you
got a tesla and then these came for you
no no these are gifts from you these are
from me yeah my gifts are better than
this oh wait
wait these are gifts
from annie to kalila but bought by jo
from the mind of george
that's basically what bobby does every
year george it's not bad
but it's
could i just say carlos did this so that
we can uh go but did you
did you tell him carlos what is this
[ __ ] yeah carlos come on this is me so
this is a bit that that's why you're
hired came up with wait annie annie
let's let's get this straight carlos i'm
getting her fake pubes and cowboy boots
like i think i'm pretty on brand with
mine yeah no but i'm saying why
how are we going to stand for this that
carlos has any power that your gift to
kyle was just tesla
i thought you were really proud of the
tesla stuff why told someone else to buy
it on amazon but this is like a waste of
our fun no this is why carlos this is
why carlos will always remain a weirdo
that has a crush on me because
he doesn't get me why do you think i
have a crush on you so badly
esther i feel like i've been does he not
exhibit so much
what i've been in your car with you
alone and what would happen if you've
never had any chemistry i from my end
you're correct but even from my end it's
like you know where you're not gonna be
in my tesla
i don't need a driver anymore you're no
longer allowed in my car this is a
misallocation of funds getting a tesla
hat for your birthday i'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of george
guess who was missing on my birthday at
my birthday party whoo
oh yeah george where are you wait esther
was actually screaming for you george we
need to help
at one point on the mic i said george so
we just got where george has been in a
terrible accident i can't make it oh i
actually remember that and felt weird i
was like
you were too high for that joke i was so
high they really were yelling for you
where the [ __ ] is george anytime we
couldn't get something to work we were
yelling did i look like i was having fun
yeah mental text he'll let you know but
like i went out to to cope with hot
springs since it was my only weekend uh
for my birthday that i was fine that we
all forgot by the way when was your
birthday the last time we recorded we
recorded on his birthday and we didn't
greet him oh i was definitely mean to
him too
so i was busy that weekend working so
this was my first weekend i could get
out with the wife and the kid go relax
um and there's no cell service or the
hotel doesn't even have wi-fi i love how
you're acting like that happened to you
and it wasn't the reason you went there
it was a beautiful uh coincidence i
didn't want to get texted about hey uh
this karaoke bar doesn't have the sound
isn't great you mind uh looking at the
levels here
do they have do what rhymes with kalila
i want to do a song
no esther was good esther and jenna were
up there but here's what i learned about
esther
you get two lines out of her a song and
then she's just like can we change the
song which is
but that is the part of karaoke you have
to get through you gotta finish the song
why
because it's not a good activity okay
i don't know why your people brought it
here to us like at the end of purple
rain when it's just the woo hoos you
gotta see it through but it was the joy
you know what i watched because i was
observing because i am so i i go on
stage i say terrible things about my own
[ __ ] on stage to strangers
singing a song in front of all of my
friends and their friends is literally
like the the worst situation i could
possibly but annie the point of karaoke
is to be terrible together yes i know
but there's something there's something
that i'll work through that i'll work on
this is a me problem
there's some childhood trauma attached
to that that i have to figure out but
can i just i i have a prediction that if
it was just the three of us that you
would have
yeah it would have been more it would
have been fine yeah i mean let's be real
i literally saw your sister one but
that is quite pretty it is rude that you
invited more than just me and annie to
your birthday but she did give us like a
really special yeah
do we have a picture of our triple kiss
or video of that yeah carl's video do
you have your phone on you yeah [ __ ]
now he's starting to get it
there you go that's better than a tesla
hat
that's getting you further getting a
little moist
oh my god
we were high look at esther was like
really in it still you were super high i
was very high yeah i was very curious
what did you do after did you just go
crash did you eat chicken fingers like
well i ate a lot well i'm on like a
program with my
my um
trainer so i was like gonna try to just
not i realized because i get the
munchies i have not tried your
suggestion yet of listerine george oh me
either because because it's not about it
really isn't about how my mouth feels
when i'm when i cry and i want to eat
it's it's not like there's no stomach
gargling it's just like i must put
grease in my mouth i feel that too but
so there were these little egg rolls
and they were sitting there for a while
carlos was actually like
trying to help me because he saw me go
for several yeah and carlos at one point
leans over and he goes in my ear he goes
i wish all these people would leave so
we could just eat all these
egg rolls
i was like i'm not not eating them
because of the people i'm not eating
them because
i
um my asian boyfriend has to leave the
egg roll eating contest
are we allowed to say that um your
trainer is tom cruise's trainer i think
so
i think so
tom cruise yeah a lot of a lot of stars
yes
i squat harder knowing that i go what
are your body goals just to get real
strong and i want to get thick ripped
that's the best the crypt i don't and
all are all good
[Laughter]
i um the way um
the way i looked before the pandemic
before i gained weight i don't i'm
actually not into that look anymore why
what was it i was just skinnier than i'd
like to be mm-hmm
i was like doing jiu jitsu and hot yoga
every day yeah you can't be doing cardio
every day it's like a twice a week thing
[ __ ] jiu-jitsu anymore either i'm not
like getting covered off of some guy's
sweat sweaty ass balls and i'm not why
i'm pretty i don't want to get my face
does your shoe jutsu teacher make you
blow him
what the [ __ ]
yeah that's a part of it that's how you
pass guard they come in your mouth
those are great body goals yeah i want
to be like because my trainer we kind of
have like a similar build like a big ass
and no tiss
so
how old were you guys when you got your
periods
i was
i want to say
13. did you have a growth spurt at all
no never yeah she was like she popped
out genuinely never
wait you got it at 11 is that true yeah
because i think actually 13 is young to
get it and it's getting younger and
younger now i just heard as early as
eight and nine my friend told me she got
her yeah she got hers at eight what i
have nieces that get it at um is that
because of like dairy like there's like
i've heard that there's oh my god she
watched a [ __ ] netflix documentary no
i heard this like literally like 15
years ago that like the hormones in cows
that cows are injected with some
something that gives women i think don't
point at me when you say cow
i think um some of it has to do with
that and also a lot of childhood obesity
oh really she wasn't obese
um then it's probably the but now you're
pointing at me when you no no no i'm
just saying the hormones mansions the
chicken hormones
wait i want to talk about the comedy
story posting really bad pictures of you
for some reason
i don't i i know you don't pay attention
but nobody tells you as your friend why
do they do that who's doing that they
are so bad it's not on price not on
purpose they just you think it's an
inside job they're not looking at us
yeah but i'm looking at you i have
theory
people dm it to me
i don't understand yeah it's weird it's
like you're just gonna sell less tickets
because you're making me look ugly
it's like esther always going back in a
bit she's going
every picture so it gives her a double
chin they do it to me too that's why you
have to have your hair in front yeah so
they can't get you but they'll put like
my stomach i'm like guys do you hate me
like are you mad at me yeah that's what
it feels like wait i want to freestyle
uh oh yes
the the gifts
never stop coming today danny do you
want to do it to
this cupcake
i'm scared to have fire near my hair but
you guys it was so funny i wish you were
there you had left
you know bet and saw it did he try to
save you
nobody could save me there was no saving
it went up it was like and then i put it
out really fast but i went to the
security guard i saved my face
i saved my face you saved my face's life
oh no
okay no no because i wanna i wanna okay
that looks good dear kalyla
um
you really not only is there a weird h
in your name
you add an h to our lives not heroin
happiness
you
uh
they might not say nice things about you
on reddit
but when it comes to this podcast you
sure can edit
um without you
the podcast would
be kind of long but not as strong
the extra time you put in
reminds me of esther's chins
uh without you
who would boss around george
oh wait the other two [ __ ]
um
i ask that whatever you get for your
birthday
you don't
use it to pay carlos
happy birthday love you
happy birthday
[Applause]
thanks guys oh i feel so special
for feeling so wrecked on the inside i
sure feel pretty special still yes how
do you feel about turning the sage i
feel really really lucky why i think
that getting older is a privilege
and i will never look at it as something
that i dread we should say to old people
like you have privilege
yeah like stop this not you don't get
your own walkway
yeah i think i feel lucky to be 37 and i
think i
look good for 37 i feel good i feel like
a kid still and that feeling will never
go away i hope
and we're all pretend adults and yeah
what's your advice to any people out
there that are 33 who uh who want to
stay young and beautiful like you
i would say facial reconstructive
surgery this is the start
i would say dr rivkin is a great we need
to get one of those stretching machines
we'll stretch you taller
some tom cruise shoes
lots of platforms hidden platforms
oh this is fun and he has a formula for
staying youthful whatever outfit this is
that's how you stay youthful yeah you
gotta stay playful i think that's the
ultimate thing don't take life too
seriously the moment you stop playing
you start getting old so just keep
playing with your friends and being
silly playing with yourself and sending
your videos to your friends and fisting
send videos of your to your friends of
fisting your own [ __ ] you know i
think that the perfect example of being
someone who's playing is getting a
tattoo of your co-workers it's just sad
that you can't like really show us i
know i wouldn't plan it right i got it
yesterday when can we do the reveal
on my because i want to post
so yeah that is that picture i showed
you was right after that he did it so
that is it but it's just healing now i
didn't realize it takes like a little
while to heal oh
but in a few days it'll be ready you
guys sh eats bananas she gets tattoos
she smokes weed i mean this girl is no
she's really you know what it is we made
fun of you and said you look like the
days of the confused guy and then you
just became
i one-upped you by becoming i love it
um you guys thank you so much for
joining us on this special episode of
trash tuesday and it's not that it's
special because it's her birthday it's
special because such an amazing tesla
present was given
and i just want to say what a great
present that i would be
giving someone
do you and you know maybe a good comment
below what did you feel like if your
co-worker got
your name tattooed on their arm
how do you feel about that
like this video subscribe you guys we
are nothing without you
these three old sperm horrors
we'll see you next week
bye
[Music]
you